the rebels are increasingly confident i
put it that way that they have met the
threshold of 54 letters that is what is
needed to be sent in to call for a
leadership challenge and if they have
met that threshold we could be hearing
about it as soon as the next couple of
hours we know that over the last 10 days
or so since mps went away for their
recess after the sue grey report there
has been pressure building mps in their
constituencies hearing discontent on the
doorsteps over partygate mixed with
other concerns but the loss of trust
over partygate has been a very big
factor here and have been
publicly or privately putting in their
letters of no confidence in the prime
minister in downing street behind me
they are braced for this happening
downing street source tells me that if
it happens today and they are braced for
that outcome then the indications are
they will want this leadership vote to
be done pretty quickly probably in the
next 24 to 48 hours they they are going
to fight it every step of the way and
they say that boris johnson
is going to tell mps that he is a winner
that he has got the plan they need to
take the country forward and in fact his
chief of staff steve barkley who we had
on the programme last week has just
published an article online saying that
aimed at conservative mps saying we've
lost half of this parliament to covid it
will be our fault entirely if we choose
to waste the remaining half on
distractions over the leadership but
certainly over the weekend there was a
briefing document circulating among
conservative rebels talking about boris
johnson's unpopularity and the fact that
he was booed at the jubilee at the saint
paul's service over the weekend that
certainly chimes with what some
conservative rebels have told me that at
jubilee street parties people coming up
to them saying it's time to change prime
minister so if it happens
moment of serious jeopardy for the prime
minister but of course if there is a
vote and he wins then he is safe from
challenge in theory for another year
and it was pretty staggering seeing um i
mean he did have some cheers but there
were very loud booze as well at
saint paul's on friday
when he was there with his wife
carrie johnson but he's being referred
to also i believe tomorrow as the
conservative corbyn what does that mean
yes in this briefing document apparently
circulating amongst conservative rebels
they say that
what um what that you saw at the jubilee
is nothing that you couldn't read in the
polls that boris johnson's popularity is
really very low a lot of conservative
mps
say that the polls suggest they will
lose the next election now of course the
next election is expected to be two
years away so these things do change but
they are very concerned that with him at
the helm they may be on course for
defeat and some of them clearly want to
change prime minister whether they have
the numbers to defeat him of course you
only need 54 for a challenge but once
you have a vote you need a majority of
conservative mps that will be 180 to
vote against the prime minister that is
a much higher bar and at the moment the
prime minister and his allies are
feeling very bullish about that vote the
cautionary tale though okay is if this
goes ahead that when prime ministers win
votes of confidence see theresa may
margaret thatcher john major they can be
very wounded and they don't tend to
carry on in office for that long
afterwards but at the moment the mood
here is very much that they are going to
fight this that the prime minister will
say he has a plan for the economy he's
got a speech this week on housing he's
got a plan for the health service and
that they will be very much putting
conservative mps saying this is not the
time to have a change of leader